ENOUGH MEMBERS SHOW FOR A QUORUM
WE DO HAVE ENOUGH TO START AS A
SUB COMMITTEE SO I'M GOING TO
START.
THE JUDICIARY SO WE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR TUESDAY MARCH
TWENTIETH.
AND MR CARLINA YOU'RE PRESENTING
FOR MISTER.
CHAU.
SO.
SINCE YOU'RE HERE LET'S DO THIS
BILL THAT TAKES THIS ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
NINE MISTER CHILD'S BILL BUT MR
KILEY IS PRESENTING.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB
SEVENTY THREE NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I CHAO WHOSE
EXCUSED FROM TODAY'S HEARING.
THIS IS A FAIRLY MINOR BUT I
IMPORTANT FIX TO.
PREVIOUS BILL PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
AT THAT TIME HAS WORKED OUT
REALLY WELL BUT WITH AYE AYE A
COUPLE OF UNFORESEEN NOT
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE OF THE
AMBIGUITIES IN THE CRAFTING SO
TWO THOUSAND FIVE FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED A NEW
NONPROFIT METHOD FOR CONVEYING
REAL PROPERTY AND THAT. CALLED
PROVOKE WILL TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED IN ORDER TO BE LEGALLY
EFFECTIVE THE DEED MUST BE
REPORTED WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
SIGNING NOW. UNDER EXISTING LAW
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THE LAW
ALSO REQUIRES ACTUALLY RECORDING
THE FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
PAGE THAT'S PART OF THE
STATUTORY FORM WHICH IS PURELY
INSTRUCTIONAL REQUIRES NO
PERSONAL INFORMATION. OUT OR
SIGNATURES
BECAUSE OF THAT AMBIGUITY THE
BENEFICIARIES OF THESE DEEDS I
THAT WERE REPORTED WITHOUT THE
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS THAT
MAY FIND IT DIFFICULT OR
IMPOSSIBLE TO OBTAIN TITLE
INSURANCE AND MAY FACE A LEGAL
CHALLENGE TO THE VALIDITY. OF
THE DEED.
IN ORDER TO AVOID THESE ARE
REALLY SERIOUS PROBLEMS ACTUALLY
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY NINE AND
EXPRESSLY STATE THAT FAQ RECORD
ATION. IS NOT REQUIRED AYE AND
SORT OF A TECHNICAL ISSUE THE
BILL WOULD APPLY THAT RULE
RETROACTIVELY BUT ONLY IF THE
TRANSFEROR IS STILL ALIVE WHEN
THE BILL TAKES EFFECT. AYE THAT
LIMITED RETROACTIVITY WOULD GIVE
THE BILL THE GREATEST BENEFICIAL
EFFECT WITHOUT IMPAIRING
ANYONE'S VESTED PROPERTY RIGHTS
I THIS IS BASED ON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF CALIFORNIA
LAW.
REVISION COMMISSION WHICH IS
DIRECTED TO STUDY THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS NEW LAW
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVEMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND OUT WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IS BRIAN HERBERT
FROM THE AFOREMENTIONED
CALIFORNIA WATER VISION
COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY CHRIS
WITH US PLEASE AND A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
BRIAN EVEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LAW REVISION COMMISSION.
I MOSTLY JUST HERE THIS MORNING
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATION ON
THAT THAT'S THE BASIS FOR THIS
BILL.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ITEM.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION.
MR MEMBERS ON TALK CALIFORNIA
ONE TITLE ASSOCIATION WERE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION BUT AFTER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION ROOM WERE MOVING
OPPOSITION.
CLT HAS CONSISTENTLY OPPOSED
TRANSFER DEATH DEEDS IN THEIR
INITIAL FORMS.
SEEN IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ELDER FINANCIAL ABUSE.
WE SAW THE FAQ'S IS A WAY TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE.
AND WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE READ THEM BOTTOM WE
HAVE BEEN PERSUADED BY THE LAW
REVISION COMMISSION AND YOUR
STAFF.
IT THROUGH THEIR ANALYSIS THAT
THE THAT.
REQUIRING THEM TO BE RECORDED
CAUSES MORE PROBLEMS.
THAN IT THAN IT SOLVES.
WE WILL BE EXPLORING OTHER
IDEAS.
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND LARA
VISION COMMISSION BUT WE WILL
NOT OPPOSE A CLARIFICATION THAT
THE FAQS NEED. NOT BE RECORDED
NOR THE RETROACTIVE APPLICATION
THAT POLICY.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OR REMOVE
OPPOSITION.
OR LET US KNOW ANYTHING.
ARE SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AS WERE A LITTLE BIT THIN RIGHT
NOW WE WILL GET THERE. ALRIGHT
THANK YOU FISCALLY MEZCLA.
I THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ANOTHER.
THANK YOU.
WAS IT THAT UP WHAT'S WE HAVE A
QUORUM I WAS SUB DOESN'T IT LONG
ENOUGH TO GET SOME MEMBERS HERE.
WE COULD SEE IF WE CAN GET
MEMBERS AND AUTHORS.
THEN WE COULD CONTINUE.
SEVERAL.
FEDERAL.
GOING BACK
YEAH HE.
STAY IN.
I. GREW UP IN.
AND THEN PUT.
BICU.
YOU CAN.
WE HAVE SIX.
CALDERON WAS DOWN HERE OBERNOLTE
HERE CALDERON.
BERMAN.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN. KALRA.
KILEY.
MAINTAIN THEIR.
FRANCE.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM OF A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE AND THERE
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT OPPOSITION
THAN NORMAL. WE HAVE THIS
OBERNOLTE SITTING IN FOR MISTER
CUNNINGHAM.
CALDERON WILL BE JOINING US FOR
MISTER CHAU.
TO BERMAN WILL BE JOINING US FOR
MR TO. ANDERSON SOUTH FLETCHER
JOINING US FOR MS GARCIA.
RIGHT.
LET'S TAKE A MOTION I THINK
MOST ON THE CONSENT AGENDA LESS
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE ANY
ITEMS FROM THE SENATE AND.
WE TWO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
KALRA PLAYS STONE AYE STONE AYE
OBERNOLTE WITH NEW MULTI AYE
CALDERON. BERMAN.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIN CHEN IRIS.
REYES I.
ALRIGHT THOSE ITEMS THE CONSENT
AGENDA AS OUT THAT IS AB TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR KALRA AB TWENTY ONE
OH FIVE MAIENSCHEIN. AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN OBERNOLTE AB TWENTY
TWO A ONE MAYES.
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN AB TWENTY THREE OH
NINE BLOOM AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
OBERNOLTE. ACR EIGHTEEN ONE
EIGHT NINE BY GALLAGHER HR SIXTY
THREE GALLAGHER AND HR EIGHTY
ONE BY MCCARTY.
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
MISTER SANTIAGO.
WHICH IS AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO
AND IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE
HEARD AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY NINE.
BY MISTER CHILD IS A KILEY
PRESENTED ALL TAKE A MOTION ON
ITEM OF ONE.
NO THE MOTION AND A SECOND ON AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY NINE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
AND THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
STONE BY STONE AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE CALDERON. BERMAN.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN. KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT AND I
WILL NOTE THAT AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE ARAB ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE
AGENDA BY THE AUTHOR.
RIGHT MISTER SANTIAGO AND MISS
CARILLO WELCOME.
I THINK WAS CARE FOR LONG IS TO
PRESENT THAT A PERSON LIKE
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES THAT
TECHNICAL NON SUBSTANTIVE.
AMENDMENTS HAVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO WOULD
APPROPRIATE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO DE US CDSS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE CURRENT OR
FORMER SABAEANS OF THE FEDERAL
TPS PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT'S IN RECENTLY I
TERMINATE ABOUT THE?
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BUT HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT
I IN PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS
DATING BACK TO THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
BUSH JUNIOR ADMINISTRATION AND
TRUMP ON FOR IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION US WE'D LIKE TO
PROPOSE THESE DOLLARS. ID BE
ABLE TO. BEGIN THE
NATURALIZATION PROCESS LEGAL
DEFENSE OR OBTAIN OTHER
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS NOW AFFECTED BY
THAT.
I IN CALIFORNIA I THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I REPRESENTS A
ONE THE AREAS THAT HAVE THE
LARGEST.
I TPS RECIPIENTS RECIPIENTS ARE
AND PEOPLE YOU KNOW MACARTHUR
PARK PARTICULARLY FROM THE
SALVADORAN COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I EXPECT
THAT'S WHEN I VOTE AND.
MISS OF CREEL WOULD ALSO
PRESENT AND WE HAVE A WITNESS
GREAT THANK YOU MISCREANT THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO COPE WITH AN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO IS A CRITICAL
MEASURE TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VIRAL VULNERABLE SECTOR NOR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. I LIKE TO
THINK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ALL STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ENSURE THIS BILL
HELPS. ALL PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS TPS.
WELL WE RECENTLY ADOPTED A
RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT TPS
RECIPIENTS FROM A SOLID OR THERE
ARE SEVERAL OTHER IMMIGRANT
GROUPS THAT REQUIRE. OUR SUPPORT
INCLUDING NICARAGUANS AND
HAITIANS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
AT THIS BILL IS ON CURRENT
EFFORTS TO ASSIST MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT HAVE BEEN
STRIPPED OF THEIR PROTECTIONS
AND MADE VULNERABLE. FOR REMOVAL
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MANY
DECADES.
THESE DEPORTATIONS WILL COST OUR
STATE THOUSANDS OF LAW ABIDING
HARDWORKING RESIDENTS WHO
CONTINUE WHO CONTRIBUTE MILLIONS
TO OUR ECONOMY. TPS RECIPIENTS
ARE ALSO PARENTS TO CHILDREN WHO
ARE U. S. BORN.
AND IF THEY ARE FORCED TO LEAVES
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WILL BE
TORN APART WHICH IS NOT.
IN LINE WITH THE VALUES OF OUR
STATE.
THESE SHIFTING FEDERAL POLICIES
LEAVE LARGE POPULATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS FEELING
EXPOSED AND HOPELESS VULNERABLE
AND FEARFUL MANY WHO HAVE.
SET ME AND TOO I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUE AND MANY OTHERS THAT
THERE'S EVEN SUICIDAL TENDENCIES
EYES SPECIALLY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WOULD NOT DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THEIR FUTURE IS LIKE. OR FOR
PARENTS WHO FEEL THAT THEY HAVE
FAILED THEIR THEIR CHILDREN IN
SOME WAY.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
HEALTHY AND THAT INCLUDES MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS. ESPECIALLY FOR
THESE VERY CRITICAL ISSUES THAT
IMPACT.
BOB THE VERY BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITIES REALLY ACROSS OUR
STATE.
SO IN RESPONSE TO THE SENSELESS
AND A TEMPORARY PROTECTEDSTATUS
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SAFEGUARD ALL CALIFORNIANS IN
RESIDENTS BY OFFERING QUALIFIED
LEGAL SERVICES. TO HELP AND
ADVICE IN THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT ARE COMMITTED
NONPROFIT PARTNERS HAVE THE
FUNDING. AND RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO UNDERTAKE THIS AYE LARGE TASK
THAT THINK YOU AND.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS PLACE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE I AM A CHILD OF THE
TPS HOLDER AND A MEMBER OF THE
CENTER MAYOR CAN RESOURCE
CENTER.
KNOWN AS COURTESY. OF CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO WHICH
WILL HELP PROVIDE DEPORTATION
DEPENDS TO INDIVIDUALS LEFT
FULLER BY THE RESULT OF THE TPS
TERMINATION FOR A SITE ABOUT THE
ORDER AND SEVERAL OTHER
COUNTRIES. I'M HERE TO TELL MY
STORY AS ONE OF THE MORE THAN
FIFTY THOUSAND U. S. BORN
CHILDREN OF TPS HOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA FILLED WITH PAIN. AND
LIVING IN FEAR BECAUSE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION TO
ANTI PRESS FOR SO MANY
COUNTRIES.
I'M A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
COLLEGE STUDENT.
AND MY FATHER'S A TPS HOLDER
FROM ASSAD WHETHER MY FATHER HAS
BEEN LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
OVER TWENTY TWO YEARS HE CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY FLEEING THE CIVIL
WAR CIVIL WAR IN IN SOME OF THE.
MY FATHER'S A MOST HARD WORKING
AND LOYAL MAN I KNOW AND I'M
AFRAID OF WHAT MAY HAPPEN TO HIM
FOR MOST TO TAKE.
HERE'S MY FAMILY HAS BEEN ABLE
TO ENJOY LIFE WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT MY FATHER'S DEPORTATION.
UNTIL THE TPS TERMINATION FOR
SALVADOR WAS ANNOUNCED IN
JANUARY. THIS TPS TERMINATION
ANNOUNCEMENT HAS TERRIFYING MY
FATHER AND AFFECTED MY ENTIRE
FAMILY.
MY FATHER HAS A WIFE
FOR CHILDREN AND THREE
GRANDCHILDREN IN THE U. S..
MY OLDER SISTERS FINISHING HER
MASTERS AND CYBERSECURITY MY
BROTHERS SERVING IN THE U. S.
ARMY AND MY YOUNGER SISTER AND I
ARE BOTH COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AS A TPS HOLDER MY FATHER WAS
ABLE TO GET A JOB AS AN
INDUSTRIAL PLUMBER AND WAS ABLE
TO PURCHASE HIS FIRST HOME.
HE PAYS HIS TAXES
LOSING TPS MEANS THAT TAXPAYERS
LIKE MY FATHER WILL LOSE THEIR
JOBS AND FAMILIES LIKE MINE WILL
BE AT RISK OF SEPARATION DUE TO
DEPORTATION. MY MOTHER IS
CURRENTLY DISABLED UNABLE TO
WORK AND I ALSO HAVE A YOUNGER
SISTER HOME. WITHOUT MY FATHER
SUPPORT I WILL HAVE TO PUT MY
COLLEGE ON HOLD TO IT IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR MY
FAMILY. I WANT TO HAVE MY FATHER
AT MY COLLEGE GRADUATION MY
FATHER'S A REASON WHY PUSH SO
HARD IN SCHOOL.
SINCE THE TERMINATION OF TIPIS
WERE SALVADORAN COMMUNITY I HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO SLEEP LARA DAY
GOES BY WITHOUT THINKING BUT THE
DAYS I HAVE LEFT WITH MY FATHER.
TODAY I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES IN A SEC
AND EXACTING SITUATION I STAND
HERE BECAUSE OF THE COURAGE AND
STRENGTH THAT MY FATHER
INSTILLED IN ME. A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY TWO WOULD BRING BACK SOME
LEVEL OF CERTAINTY. AND HOPED TO
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY FIND THEMSELVES IN
NEED OF DEPORTATION
REPRESENTATION. CALIFORNIA MUST
LEAD IN ENSURING THAT TPS
HOLDERS IN OUR STATE WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGAL REPRESENTATION
AFTER THE IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND.
A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO WILL
HELP
TO PROVIDE JUSTICE TO THOSE
AFFECTED BY TPS TERMINATIONS AND
KEEP FAMILIES LIKE MINE
TOGETHER.
ON BEHALF OF OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
U. S. CHILDREN OF TPS HOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA I ASK FOR YOUR ABLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM.
EXPERTS.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT ALSO
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL TPS
ALLIANCE.
KEVIN ANDERSON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS GALIANO UP THE CALIFORNIA
MIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
BUT I THINK ANY TIME WE HAVE SAY
STILL CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
PLEASE SURGERIES WITH WALKER
GROUP ON BEHALF OF CATHOLIC
CHARITIES THE CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
ALEXANDER MORALE IS ON THE HAVE
GOT A SAN AND THE NATIONAL TPS
ALLIANCE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PAY ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SING NOT OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTION.
THOMAS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
QUESTIONS COME.
THREATS.
STEPHANIE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR COMING TO GIVE TESTIMONY
OFTENTIMES.
THE TESTIMONY OF WITNESSES SUCH
AS YOURSELF OR VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE REST OF US AND TO THOSE WHO
ARE LISTENING.
TO BE SURE TO HEAR THE STORIES.
THE HUMAN STORIES AND THE.
THE FACE OF THOSE WERE GOING TO
BE AFFECTED AND CONGRATULATIONS
ON BEING IN COLLEGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
ABOUT.
IN I JUST WANNA MAKE THE POINT
THAT A THE.
ISSUE THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY IS NOT WHETHER OR NOT.
TPI SHOULD BE ENDED OR WHETHER
OR NOT THAT'S A FAIR THING TO DO
TOO THE. IMMIGRANTS THAT.
ARE HERE AS A RESULT OF THAT
PROGRAM WERE DISCUSSING WHETHER
OR NOT TO ALLOCATE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY TO THE
LEGAL DEFENSE OF A PEOPLE WHO.
ARE POSING A.
A CHANGE IN FEDERAL LAW.
SO. I HAVE TO RESPECT WOULD BE
IN OPPOSITION ARE BUT I WANTED
TO TELL YOU WHY. I IN ON VICE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND. WE EVERY YEAR GRAPPLE WITH
THOUSANDS OF VERY WORTHY CAUSES
WHO COME BEFORE US AND. MAKE
THEIR PITCH FOR WHY WE SHOULD
FUND WITH TAXPAYER MONEY THE
PARTICULAR PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE SO IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT DECISION TO FIGURE
OUT.
WHICH CAUSES ARE WORTHY BUT
WHICH IS WHICH ARE NOT WORTHY
HAD TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO A
LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY AND.
I'M CONCERNED THAT WERE NOT
BEING DELIVERED ENOUGH IN.
.
HAVING A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
OTHER USES TO WHICH THAT MONEY
CAN BE PUT SO WILL GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES WE COULD FUND OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
MAMMOGRAMS HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MAMMOGRAMS WITH THAT
MONEY. WE COULD FIND ALMOST
THREE THOUSAND SEMESTERS OF CS
YOU TUITION AND AS YOU KNOW IN
THE BUDGET THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE DEBATING THIS YEAR WHETHER
OR NOT. WE SHOULD BE INCREASING
TUITION ON THOSE STUDENTS OR
WHETHER NOT MORE STATE FUNDING
UNNECESSARY SO. OTHER THOSE THE
REASONS WHY I RESPECTFULLY HAVE
TO POSE A BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU AND I'LL JUST SAY THAT
THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE AND
THE POLICY THAT IS IN QUESTION
IS WHETHER OR NOT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD FIND IT.
OUR VALUES TO SUPPORT.
THE TPS.
THOSE WHO ARE POTENTIALLY BEING
DENIED TPS STATUS IN CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY THIS WILL GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS
SO GO TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE NEXT
HUMAN SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WHERE THOSE
BALANCING. ACTS CAN HAPPEN
WHAT'S BEFORE US IS.
NOT THE BUDGET QUESTION BUT
MERELY STATEMENTS OF WHETHER OR
NOT WE FEEL THAT THIS COMMITTEE
FEELS THAT THIS.
BILL AS A POLICY BILL MEETS OUR
STANDARDS.
THANK YOU.
THE DRESS.
I THINK ALSO TO THE COMMENT I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT UBER
TALKING ABOUT.
USING TAXPAYERS MONEY.
IT'S CLEAR THE TPS THOSE WERE
PROTECTED BY TPS.
OUR TAXPAYERS.
OTHER CHILDREN ARE US BORN.
TAXPAYERS
AND THEY DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTION THEY DESERVE TO HAVE.
THE FUNDS THAT ARE IN THE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND THE
FEDERAL BUDGET. TO BE USED FOR
THE PROTECTION.
OF ALL FAMILIES.
JUST MY RESPONSE THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
SING NONE ARE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO HUMAN
SERVICES.
JOINT TO CLOSE AYE YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE UP
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENT ON THE
QUESTION A TAXPAYERS. UP THIS
VOTE COMES DOWN TO A BASIC
QUESTION OF VALUES DO YOU VALUE
OR DO YOU NOT. IN A POLICY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU EXPECT LAST
PRIVATE THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
THINK ILL ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE IN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
IF THE MOTION A SECOND CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NO
CALDERON.
BERMAN GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE SO
WE'LL PUT THAT ITEM ON CALL.
THANK YOU
SANTIAGO YOU ALSO OF ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE.
I'LL BE BRIEF AT THE CHURCH OKAY
WITHOUT.
WE'RE FINE WITH THAT.
SOME TEARS WANT TO GO LONG
ENOUGH.
DEBORAH'S AT MY BILL.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE
WHICH UPDATES COMMERCIAL
ABANDONED PROPERTY LAWS BY
INCREASING THE THRESHOLD AMOUNT
THAT IS NEEDED. TUCKED TRIGGERED
THE OFFICIAL AUCTION PROCESS A
ONE STAR BY THINK IN THE
COMMITTEE I STAFF UP FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS MEASURE AND HELPING
US WITH THE ARM AMENDMENTS.
BUT MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
WITNESS THANK YOU.
WITNESS WAYS MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATTHEW HARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
FOR THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
PROPOSED.
AS AMENDED THE BILL WOULD.
BASICALLY HADN'T PROVIDE A
MODEST RAISING THE THRESHOLD TO
TRIGGER THE AUCTION PROCESS FOR
PROPERTY THAT'S LEFT OVER IN A
COMMERCIAL. SETTING.
THE INTENT LANGUAGE WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE SEPARATES OUT.
THAT THIS IS NOT A RESIDENTIAL
ISSUE AND SHOULD HAVE IMPACT ON
RESIDENTIAL AND WITH THAT WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE.
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
AND WHO ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SING NOT US ANY OPPOSITION.
SAY NOT QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ISRAEL. I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THAT.
RESIDENTIAL TENANTS ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS OTHERWISE
CERTAIN IT WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN
IN IN FAVOR OF THIS.
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SINGER SANTIAGO YOU MIKLOS
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I DON'T.
THANK YOU.
SO IT'S DO PASS AS AMENDED CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE
CALDERON BERMAN. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I RAISE. RATES I.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
ACR WHEN SEVENTY TWO MISTER LOW.
BOB GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO REPRESENT ACR
ONCE HAVE NEED TO S. IS AN
APOLOGY. PUFF OF ACTS TOWARDS
THE LGBT COMMUNITY HOW WE AS A
STATE HOPE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
WE ARE A STATE OF INCLUSION
VERSUS EXCLUSION. AND WE WANT TO
RIGHT THE WRONGS OF THE PAST OF
THIS SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR THE STATE
TO IDENTIFY A NUMBER OF THE
VARIOUS ACTS THAT THAT'S
HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
AT SO THAT WE CAN. ENSURE THAT
WE DO NOT REPEAT IT AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD UP FOR
YOUR.
.
PRESENTATION HERE I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT JUST.
A FEW.
ACTS THAT HAVE BEEN PART OF
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
I AS STATED PUBLIC INDECENCY
STATUTES AND UNLAWFUL MASQUERADE
LAWS WERE APPLIED TO PERMIT
POLICE TO HARASS AND SOMETIMES
ARREST.
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONSIDERED
DEVIANT.
AND OR GENDER BENDING.
I IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE IT
CALIFORNIAN ACTED A SEXUAL
PSYCHOPATH LAW WHICH WAS USED TO
COMMIT. NUMEROUS LGBT PEOPLE FOR
INVOLUNTARY PSYCHIATRIC
INCARCERATION AND GRUESOME
MEDICAL TREATMENTS.
A AND SO.
WE WANT TO STAND FIRM AS A STATE
TO DEMONSTRATE OUR LOVE AND
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITY AND
LEAD NOT ONLY IN OUR STATE BUT
IN THE NATION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT A WITH ME ALSO IT ARE
MEMBERS OF A CO YOU AND EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
GOOD MORNING ALICE KESSLER HERE
ON BEHALF OF A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
I WANTED TO SHARE THAT A LOT OF
THE FOCUS OF OUR ORGANIZATION AT
THIS TIME IS ADDRESSING THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY. AND WE SEE THAT
THEY'RE POOR OUTCOMES WHETHER
IT'S AROUND MENTAL HEALTH FAMILY
REJECTION. HIGHER RATES OF
SUICIDE POORER HEALTH CARE
OUTCOMES.
IN A LOT OF THIS IS BECAUSE OF
THIS HISTORY OF DISCRIMINATION
UNDER THE LAW.
AND WHILE WE'VE COME A REALLY
LONG WHY ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
OF OF BRINGING OUR STATE.
TO BE ONE OF MOST PROTECTIVE OF
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY ON
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE PAST THEM HARM
IT'S DONE. AND THERE'S STILL A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO THAT THE
STRUGGLE CONTINUES SO.
WE THINK MR LOW AND THE CAUCUS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT'S A
IT'S A SYMBOLIC GESTURE BUT IT'S
ONE THAT SENDS A VERY POWERFUL
MESSAGE
TO MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT
WERE PART OF THE FABRIC OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT WERE
LOVED AND CELEBRATED. URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH WOODS.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA. AND ONE
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION THAT
RECOGNIZED AS AND GIVES VOICE
TO.
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY OF
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST LGBTQ
PERSONS AND THE HARM THAT HAS
RESULTED FROM THOSE LAWS.
WHILE CALIFORNIA'S LAWS MORE
RECENTLY HAVE BECOME MUCH MORE
INCLUSIVE AND PROTECTIVE OF
LGBTQ CALIFORNIANS. THIS HISTORY
THAT OUR STATE HAS OF
CRIMINALIZING AND DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY HAS
CREATED LONG LASTING HARM. AS MY
COLLEAGUE ALEX WAS IT POINTED
OUT SOME OF THOSE CONTINUING
REPERCUSSIONS.
BUT KNOWLEDGE IN AND APOLOGIZING
FOR CALIFORNIA HAS PASSED LGBTQ
DISCRIMINATION.
ACR WHEN SEVENTY TWO GIVES VOICE
TO THE HARM THE STATE HAS DONE
FOSTER PROMISING TO PRO ACTIVELY
REMEDY THE HARMS AND ADDRESSED.
THE. THE STATE'S LAWS TO MAKE IT
IN EVEN SAFER AND MORE EQUAL
PLACE FOR THE LGBTQ MEANT Q.
COMMUNITY AND FOR THESE REASONS
THE ACLU ISN'T A PART.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE A COMMERCIAL  FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND.
OFTENTIMES IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
GO THROUGH AND CLEAN UP THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY HAS BEEN
WORKING ON CLEANING UP. OLD THAT
IT HAD A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT
ESPECIALLY DISCRIMINATORY
EFFECT.
BUT IN THE CASE OF THE LGBT IQ
COMMUNITIES WHILE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS THAT WERE NOT NECESSARILY
TARGETED TOWARDS THAT COMMUNITY
HAVE BEEN USED AGAINST THAT CAN
BE.
AND SO FOR THE. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A STEP BACK.
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
DISCRIMINATORY LOSS WHICH WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO BUT TO TAKE
A STEP BACK.
AND.
ISSUE AN APOLOGY MAKE A VERY
CLEAR STATEMENT THAT WE WILL NOT
BROKE LAWS BEING USED FOR
DISCRIMINATORY PURPOSES AND THAT
WE INTEND TO CLEAN UP THE LAWS
TO TAKE A DISCRIMINATION NOT I
THINK IT'S A VERY APPROPRIATE
STATEMENT.
ADDRESS.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THEY
OFTEN SAY THAT TOO FOR REAL
HEALING IT ISN'T JUST TO
APOLOGIZE BUT ALSO PROMISE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
CYPRESS SHAPE THAT WE HAVE BOTH
THOSE IN THIS
IN THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU.
Q. ANYONE ELSE.
TING NOT.
SO YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU STILL NEED A
MOTION THE MOTION WOULD BE THAT
THIS ACR BE ADOPTED.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU PUT A LITTLE PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE OBERNOLTE.
CALDERON. BERMAN.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY.
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY FOUR
MS RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
FOUR A BILL THAT WILL HELP
ENSURE EQUITY IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS BY MANDATING THAT WE
HAVE COURT REPORTERS PRESIDENT
CHILD CUSTODY AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROCEEDINGS.
I TOOK AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE
CHILD CUSTODY PROCEEDINGS IN
ADDITION TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROCEEDINGS.
ACCESS TO A A VERBATIM
TRANSCRIPT IS CRITICAL AYE AND
CRITICAL COMPONENT DURING COURT
HEARINGS WHERE PARTY'S
OVERWHELMINGLY REPRESENT
THEMSELVES.
THE LACK OF COURT REPORTERS IN
FAMILY COURT CASES HAS CREATED
MANY ISSUES PARTICULARLY AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
CUSTODY. PROTECTIVE ORDERS
WITHOUT A RECORD OF THE HEARING.
LITIGANTS ARE UNABLE TO APPEAL
DECISIONS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE CONTRARY TO VICTIMS
SAFETY WE NEED TO BE PATIENT AND
PROVIDE CHILDREN AND FAMILY.
WITH.
THE SUPPORT IT INTERVENTIONS
THEY NEED TO START A SUCCESSFUL
UP PAT HERE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
A WITNESS NUMBER ONE I HAVE
JENNIFER WAXMAN DIRECTOR OF
PROGRAMS FOR IT FAMILY VIOLENCE.
ACT APPELLATE.
PROJECT ARABIC NOT YOU HERNANDEZ
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION AND
I ALSO HAVE A BROOKLINE
IMMEDIATE PAST PAIRS PRESIDENT
THINK.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
I HAVE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JENNIFER.
I JENNIFER DORFMAN WAGNER I AND
THE DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR
FAMILY BALANCE A PILOT PROJECT.
FAMILY BALANCE THE PILOT PROJECT
WAS FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE TO HELP LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME SURVIVORS OF FAMILY
VIOLENCE.
OBTAIN EFFECTIVE APPELLATE
REPRESENTATION WE ARE A STATE
BAR FUNDED SUPPORT CENTER FOR
LEGAL AID PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE SUBMITTED SIMILAR TESTIMONY
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO THE FUTURES
COMMISSION. APPOINTED BY THE
CHIEF JUSTICE IN WHICH WE WERE
JOINED BY TWENTY ONE PUBLIC
INTEREST ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE
NO DOUBT THESE ORGANIZATIONS
WILL ALSO JOIN IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO IS RAISING THE ISSUE OF
HOW TO PROVIDE A VERBATIM RECORD
AND FAMILY VIOLENCE AND CUSTODY
CASES.
AND THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
HOLDING A HEARING ABOUT THIS
VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
AS SET FORTH IN OUR WRITTEN
SUBMISSION THE CREATION OF A
VERBATIM RECORD IS ESSENTIAL FOR
PROCEEDINGS INVOLVING SURVIVORS
OF FAMILY VIOLENCE.
I WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS OUR
COMMENTS TODAY ON THE PRAGMATIC
REASONS WHY THIS IS SO.
EVEN BEFORE THE NEED FOR AN
APPEAL ARISES ACCESS TO A
VERBATIM TRANSCRIPT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THOSE
LITIGANTS AT THE TRIAL LEVEL.
WHERE THEY ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
APPEARING ON THEIR OWN BEHALF?
FIRST VERBATIM RECORDS ARE
NEEDED TO CRAFT ACCURATE POST
HEARING RESTRAINING ORDERS OR
CHILD CUSTODY IN BUSINESS
VISITATION ORDERS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CAN
ENFORCE.
SECOND VERBATIM RECORDS ARE
NEEDED BECAUSE CUSTODY AND
VISITATION CASES ARE FREQUENTLY
LITIGATED. AND REVISITED OVER
MANY YEARS.
COURT NEEDS A CLEAR RECORD OF
PAST PROCEEDINGS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGE CIRCUMSTANCES
REQUIRE ALTERING CUSTODY OR
VISITATION SCHEDULES.
MORE OVER FAMILY JUDGES OFTEN
ONLY SERVED ONE OR TWO YEARS SO
LATER JUDGES ASSIGNED TO A CASE
NEED A CLEAR RECORD OF WHAT HAS
PREVIOUSLY HAPPENED IN THE CASE
TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE CASE.
A VERBATIM RECORD IS ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL ON APPEAL.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE APPEAL IN
MANY CASES WILL BE DISMISSED OR
DENIED WITHOUT A REPORTER'S
TRANSCRIPT.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
GRANTED REVIEW IN THE CASE
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE JAMESON
VERSUS DOSTA WHERE THE APPELLATE
COURT HELD THAT THE LACK OF A
REPORTER'S TRANSCRIPT PRECLUDED.
THE REPRESENT OUR THE LITIGANT
REPRESENTING HIMSELF FROM
ATTAINING A REVERSAL OF THE
GRANT OF A MOTION FOR NON SUIT.
DUE TO THE LARGE VOLUME
UNLIMITED JUDICIARY SOURCES
WRITTEN OPINIONS ARE THE EXCESS
XIN AND FAMILY VIOLENCE CASES.
AND EVEN WHEN THEY EXIST THEY
OFTEN DO NOT SET FORTH THE
FINDINGS THAT SERVICE THE BASIS
FOR AN APPEAL.
IN MOST OF FAMILY VIOLENCE THE
PILOT PROJECTS CASES EVIDENTIARY
OR TESTIMONIAL ISSUES NOT
CONTAINED IN A WRITTEN ORDER.
ARE THE ISSUE ON APPEAL.
SINCE THESE APPEALS ARRIVE IN
CASES INVOLVING FACT INTENSIVE
REQUESTS FOR RESTRAINING ORDERS
AND CUSTODY TERMINATIONS.
THESE FACTOR TERMINATIONS AND
THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTING OR
CONTRADICTING THEM WILL NEARLY
ALWAYS BE AT ISSUE ON APPEAL.
MORE OVER AGREED OR SETTLED
STATEMENTS ARE NOT A REALISTIC
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE GREAT
MAJORITY OF FAMILY VIOLENCE THE
PILOT PROJECTS CLIENTS.
AN AGREED STATEMENT REQUIRES THE
VICTIM TO COLLABORATE WITH THEIR
ABUSER. EITHER DIRECTLY OR FROM
THE DIS ADVANTAGEOUS POSITION OF
A PRO SE LITIGANT FACING
PROFESSIONAL COUNSEL THEM BY A
TEACHER WRAP UP THE A SURE. I'M
JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
AN UPDATE AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAR SO SEASON RECENTLY POSTED
THAT AS RECENTLY AS TWENTY
SIXTEEN ONLY FIFTEEN COURTS WERE
RIPPED WHERE WERE. PROVIDING
COURT REPORTERS AND ALL FAMILY
LAW CASES SO THIS IS A
CONTINUING ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERCENT NOT
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT PORTERS
ASSOCIATIONAL BE BRIEF I THINK
THE PARENTS COVER. MOST OF THE
THE KEY ISSUES ARE NUMBER ONE I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING THIS ISSUE FOR THIS BILL
FORD ALSO WANNA THANK.
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
AND THE P. COMMITTEE STAFF I
KNOW WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS ISSUE OVER
THE YEARS AND AND THANK YOU FOR
TIRELESS. ADVOCACY ON ON THIS
ISSUE I'M JUST A COUPLE OF
THINGS YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT A
BILLS AND BUDGET DEBATES.
ABOUT THE FUNDING OF THE COURTS
AND OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA CORPORATE STATE
JUDICIARY LAST NIGHT.
WE OFTENTIMES OVERLOOKING FORGET
TO TALK ABOUT THE DAY TO DAY
GRIND THAT PARTIES FACE.
AND WE MAY HAVE THE BUILDINGS
OPEN WE MAY HELP THEIR
COURTROOMS OPEN WE MIGHT WE MAY
PROVIDE THE FUNDING FOR THAT.
THE PARTIES.
SHOW UP COURT EVERY DAY DON'T
HAVE ALL THE PROTECTIONS DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CHALLENGE
DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE IN
COURT.
THEM REALLY WHAT WE PROVIDING.
WE BELIEVE ALL OUR.
PARTNERS IN THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN
FOR THIS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN.
THANK YOU.
HOW HOW CHAIRMAN AND? MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BURKE RANDOM IMMEDIATE
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR AND I URGE
RIGHT VOTE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU DON'T LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS SIDE
OF.
IT'S OUT YET KELLY BUOYED UP
WITH BBC PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF FAMILY JUSTICE
ADVOCATES INACTION A WERE
DEDICATED TO ENSURING EQUAL
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR FAMILIES.
AND CHILD SAFETY THROUGH THIS
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. GIVE HIS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU.
IT IS RUBIO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WE HAVE. ATTEMPTED THIS
TO THE BUDGET PROCESS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS TO INSURE THAT
WE GET COURT REPORTERS OR AT
LEAST GET COURT REPORTERS IN
FAMILY LAW.
THIS IS.
ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO DO TRIED I DO
THAT LET'S TRY IT AGAIN DIED AND
I APPRECIATE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED.
TO NOT LOSE SIGHT OF HOW
IMPORTANT IT IT REALLY IS.
MORE MORE LITIGANTS ARE PRO SAY
WITHOUT A RECORD THERE'S NOT
MUCH THEY CAN DO AND THAT'S
WHAT'S SO IMPORTANT WE ALL KNOW
IT'S BEEN STATED HERE. AGAIN AND
AGAIN IN THE AT LEAST SINCE I'VE
BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE THAT THE
GOLD STANDARD FOR THAT RECORD.
ARE THE COURT REPORTERS WHO ARE.
PROVIDING THAT RECORD IN DOING
THAT FOR US SO I.
WISH YOU LUCK IN GETTING THIS
THROUGH YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE MY
SUPPORT. AND HOPEFULLY THIS
COMMITTEE'S SUPPORT AS WELL AS
WE MOVE FORWARD.
ANOTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE IS RUBIO YUMIKO
THANK YOU CLOSE FARMING THINK I
APPRECIATE IT AND I JUST TO ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE OBERNOLTE.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
GREAT THAT BILL IS OUT SINK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S GO BACK TO THE
ITEM THAT'S ON CALL ON THE LIFT
THE CALL IN ITEM NUMBER TWO.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO SANTIAGO
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CALDERON
CALDERON AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
IT'S GO BACK THROUGH SO ALL THE
BILLS ARE OUT LET'S GO.
LET PEOPLE ADD ON STARTING WITH
THE CONSENT AGENDA COLLAPSE IN
THEM. CALDERON.
CALDERON I BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY NINE CHAU.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE SANTIAGO.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE KILEY.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER SIX ACR ONE
SEVENTY TWO LOW.
OBERNOLTE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
KILEY.
I THINK WE HAVE EVERYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM.
SO WILL THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ANOTHER FEW MINUTES AND MAKE
SURE THAT ANYBODY WANTS TO VOTE
AND VOTE.
THANK YOU
BUT.
OKAY WE'VE TESTS IN ITS CONSENT.
ONE TWO.
RE. FOR.
AND SECOND OF ALL. OK. SO SORRY
WITH CONSENT CALYPSO NUMBERS
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM ONE AB SEVENTY THIRTY NINE
CHAU. KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. C.'S.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO SANTIAGO
KILEY.
VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE SANTIAGO.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOR A TWENTY THREE
FIFTY FOUR RUBIO.
OBERNOLTE KILEY.
NOT.
HOW VOTING?
SAID I REMEMBER SIX ACR ONE
SEVENTY TWO LOW OBERNOLTE KILEY.
IF YOU
HEY.
SO WE'RE GONNA CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ON A COUPLE OF ITEMS
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY FOUR RUBIO.
OBERNOLTE.
NO.
OBERNOLTE NO.
AND THEN I'D NUMBER SIX ACR ONE
SEVENTY TWO LOW.
OBERNOLTE NOT.
ABOUT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THAT COMPLETES
OUR BUSINESS FOR THE DAY WE ARE
ADJOURNED